holy Stromboli cannoli is a lien over
here buddy bop be boobity boo I had a
lot of stuff to talk about we're gonna
get to it but we've had two little
action items that have happened in the
last hour
- yeah and I'm glad it's oh we're
recording 342 on Monday - little nuggets
and news that I'd like to touch on right
off the top Sims let's head on it's the
beauty of waiting a little bit to record
the podcast number one number one
something we talked about a few weeks
ago our pads hands are falling off
Patrick Peterson I believe demands a
trade dumb man it was either demand or
requested but either way Patrick
Peterson wants a trade and here we were
a few weeks ago talking about
desperately once out as it was you said
the Patriots should call about I don't
know a guy like Patrick Peterson
well here's Patrick Peterson he wants
out I understand it he's getting up
there in years what I witnessed on
Thursday they fire their offensive
coordinator Byron Leftwich is taking
over which is incredible because you
were drafted in the same year yeah as
Byron Leftwich I played Madden with
Byron Leftwich and eighth and P P P
squared is looking around going I don't
want to be here anymore and I get it so
now who should call who should call for
them
first up yes Patriots make sense
Patriots doesn't make sense
Chiefs make sense she's definitely makes
sense my Eagles make sense your Eagles
do make sense and you still have draft
picks available right yeah another team
that would make sense is I mean the New
Orleans Saints they're not they can use
another cover corner on that side of the
whole deal giveaway but what hits Berg
Steelers I mean you could go through
there's a lot of teams that need corner
definitely is what do you think it's
gonna cost to get Patrick and the
Washington Redskins you could go through
the list and go I like to think of the
teams that are a legitimate contender
right that's why Saints Patriots Eagles
who was Chiefs I think the most makes
the most sense I know I don't really
care if Washington gets Patrick Peterson
what about the Chargers but they go to s
I know they need they don't need it need
it but it certainly would help also what
think the Cardinals oh I'm gonna learn
of my Bleacher Report @br app downloaded
get notifications like your favorite
podcast to us that am left go Patrick
Peterson's cousin Brian McFadden tweets
the ideal destination is the Saints yes
literally as you just said that
apparently he wants NOLA
well him out with Marcus Lattimore where
did he go to college LSU right yep part
of the country and makes sense you think
that the Cardinals would go Patrick
where would you like to be traded to and
then we'll see if we can get
compensation that's enough I think they
will actually grant him the respect and
at least an asking him that whether they
listen to that no I don't think it's
gonna matter what do you have to give up
to get Patrick Peterson ooh I mean this
is eighth year of his career yes we need
to look up his contract situation are
you looking but he's still a top fledged
corner yeah he is he's not like he's 28
years he's 20 years old he's just coming
towards the end of his peak and slightly
coming downhill right right well top ten
corner in the NFL yes he is I mean yes
he's right there on the fringe for me oh
yes he is a very highly paid corner if
my internet could work I could get it
for me the same problem my question that
I'm having for you is is this a
second-round pick
is this a third-round pick or is it what
we saw with a Morey Cooper as a
first-round pick Amari is throwing
everything off because Amari the Cowboys
should not have given up a first-round
pick I think that's crazy I think it's
crazy to I'll get to that in a second
what do you think is realistic not
including Amari Cooper Amari Cooper for
a first-round pick of Sammy Watkins
getting a six late first round second
round pick I mean you look at the Saints
the brish you they have is what they
traded their first-round pick away to
get Marcus Davenport so now they're
gonna have to go further down the line
as your Internet's still not working I'm
in all right Patrick Peters and trending
players but I yeah I think around that
and I do want to see his total contract
situation cuz that that certainly will
play a factor in this weather how much
money he is due to be made how many
years he
left on his deal altogether I think he
secured up for at least one or two more
years I want to say as soon as our
internet starts to work here I'll be on
that because honestly it really doesn't
impact anything yes just numbers right I
need your attention
yeah the way from you're not look at me
yeah you're not looking at going trying
to figure this out it's gonna drive me
crazy until I hey where do you want him
to go I want them to go to the Saints I
think out of all the teams Saints over
change so are the Chiefs one of those
two yes why not patron because you're
dumb because yeah I mean they've had
enough
how many things they gotta have it in
their life I mean yes being awesome to
see them go to the Patriots yes but I
want on the Chiefs you want him on the
Chamberlain I won't be to make the call
and get him on the Chiefs I think he
look cool and achieves Jersey right and
I'd like a guy that's that fast to be on
the same team as Terry you're in the
window go for it
you need it yes they really do they need
that other cover guy all right other
trade yeah Amari Cooper goes to the cut
it's really I mean I'm literally getting
a 504 gateway timeout that's what I said
what am i at a public library ah Amari
Cooper to the Cowboys first round pick
one did the Cowboys need to make a move
for a wide receiver was that what they
were missing because I watched
Washington Dallas yesterday and I didn't
immediately go man they don't have
enough wide receivers that are getting
open I'm looking at the offensive line
I'm looking at dak and I'm going I'm not
seeing anything from ya know there's the
offenses not capable of and know the
offense is not capable of doing anything
special that's for sure I mean because
the pass game schematics or nothing
groundbreaking it's kind of simple
do they need another receiver yes they
definitely do and it will come into play
in games where they can dominate you
know the offensive line of scrimmage
more yesterday they couldn't do that so
then the Redskins were never put in a
position to go well we have to
compromise ourselves on the back end a
little bit and get in some single safety
defense or play man-to-man to stop the
run so that's the real issue this is a
lot they're playing this for the long
play I'm sure this is for but a more
it's gonna be up for a contract very
soon as is v your option coming up right
so they have them for the rest of this
year and next year we held that but a
first-round pick
oh wait and see for a guy that we
haven't really seen do anything the last
two years first-round pick for a guy who
has been incredibly inconsistent to the
last two years and has good thing he
came in here and fix that good thing he
did that
good old 4 504 gateway timeout we are an
Internet company welcome to not the
internet here at bleacher report and all
but either way oh no we can't talk about
that all right well no I'd rather hear
you talk about [ __ ] Amari Cooper
Amari Cooper I know why Jon Gruden got
got rid of him I mean you got to be
thinking that Jon Gruden picked up the
phone and said Reggie like this is crazy
I thought you'd have to give up a
third-round pick four Amari Cooper yeah
I could have seen a second cuz he is
still young in this prime of his career
but for a guy who is not going to endear
himself to a head coach who's brand-new
there he's been underperforming and now
you're gonna go gosh I have no feel for
this guy in a personal level he has no
charisma he doesn't really communicate
with me very well all he does is open
his eyes and then open him a little
wider when he agrees or disagrees I mean
that's what Amari Cooper does you talk
to anybody
I mean I've even talked to other people
medias and a member out there in the Bay
Area it's nobody can get a read in a
market that's what's scary so when
things aren't good like we've said in
weeks past no that's when the head coach
is gonna go okay it's not good in the
field I don't know if I'm what I'm
really saying is getting through to this
individual yes he gives me no feedback
so I need to get him out of here and
start new with some new toys so kudos
for the Raiders to do that and yes the
Cowboys are making a desperate ploy here
to change their team around mid season
right now and add a new piece because
they still feel like the NFC East is
within reach and it is within hoarseness
and that's what I'm trying to tell a
girls fans has calmed down that the
division leader is four and two and so
they're not that far away oh they're not
but the Raiders on the other side three
first-round picks next year man so two
years ago we're sitting there going the
Raiders is there a better trio of Amari
Cooper dare
Carr and Khalil Mac and Derek cars the
only one left they don't have to pay
money for Khalil Mac they don't have to
pay money for Amari Cooper
Derek cars contract was not that crazy
right they have a lot of money to spend
right now and three first-round picks I
will say this what did they get for Colt
Miller do we know what they did bring it
back and I think they got mid round
picks nothing that crazy didn't want to
look it up I don't trust this internet
it's [ __ ] garbage so lay off me back
but I think the reason I feel like all
of a sudden getting a first-round pick
for Amari Cooper was great and kudos to
John Gordon for that but we have a
problem in our society of valuating of
valuing giraffe pics more than proven
commodity that's not we look at three
first-round picks and we go that could
be three Akula max that could be three
Derek cars it most likely will not be
think about all the big-time trades in
the past Julio Jones gets the Browns
five picks none of them are on the team
we see this all the time carson wentz
think about all the draft picks the
Browns got Cori Coleman's not on a team
like all those picks are nothing yeah no
I know me so unless Jon Gruden knows how
to draft and I'm sitting here looking at
who we got this year and they got some
good pieces yeah but we don't know what
those are gonna be no you don't it's
that's the unknown but I think the the
thing he knows just with this particular
case here this one I guess he knows what
he knows with Amari Cooper and he
doesn't like what he sees and I I think
this is a win-win for both sides like
yeah great for great for the Raiders
they accumulate the pick and then Amari
Cooper needs a fresh start
it's just I feel like people are on him
out there there's certainly questions
Derrick cars definitely lost confidence
in them and I could tell you through
play calling and play designer Jon
Gruden certainly not doing a lot around
him either which tells me he's lost
confidence especially when he came in as
hard as he did in the offseason to go oh
he's gonna be my toy and we're gonna get
him off my main option right so can you
to me there was an issue let me get the
Sims prediction the hell with it
do you yeah I don't really care do you
see
Amari Cooper having success for the
Cowboys this season
um to a degree I'm not gonna say that
it's gonna be anything groundbreaking I
think the one thing you'll see is of dak
Prescott sees him one-on-one he's gonna
be willing to take shots at least for
him he's gonna be told by the coaches we
traded for this guy so if you see him
one-on-one
take those shots yes and then I think
they'll also try to let him have some of
the tabe on Austin roll of the speed
sweeps and some of those things as well
they're gonna try to get their money's
worth out of them but I don't know what
to think of a mari Cooper I really don't
flipside yeah what are aiders players
telling each other right now that it's a
rebuild year that seasons they're
they've they've thrown in the white
towel so what happens to a team yeah
they're coming off of there by the face
of their defense left and they dealt
with that for a few weeks then the guy
that the whole offseason the coach goes
this is our main weapon they trade him
well how do they continue to get up for
games um this is the beauty of the NFL
do you want a job next year oh your
contracts not guaranteed better [ __ ]
play good cuz the head coach is still
gonna be there for nine more years as we
know right now so if you want to play
for the Raiders you better impress them
for the last ten weeks of the season you
know that's where the NFL is dangerous
everybody is fighting for their lives on
that football team other than like five
people right we've discussed that I mean
you know hey the quarterbacks he's good
to go
caliche family assembly is good to go
Rodney Hudson he's good to go you know
Gabe Jackson he's good to go
everybody else is unnoticed on that
football team is just playing for their
job and a future audition whether that's
with the Raiders or somebody else Wow
I know and then John's not gonna give up
dude I mean John's there so hard yeah so
hard I know but you know what if he
watched Sunday Night Football I'd hit
reset too because you're not competing
with Patrick mahomes and the Chiefs no
unless you hit the reset button hard I
want to say that no matter what happens
in my bets no matter what happens during
the day of the Eagles loose I wish that
Chiefs could play on Sunday night every
week because there is something blissful
about turning on a game and seeing an
executed game plan to perfection on a
weekly basis yeah
athletic ability speed
quickness X's and O's it is such a
beautiful thing to watch and I really
would like the Chiefs to play on Sunday
Night Football every week yeah I think
as a country we deserve it oh I believe
that we deserve three hours of smiling
of Patrick mahomes on the side oh and
and and just randomly throwing to Tyree
kill 70 yards down the field and it's
open right I think we deserve that as a
country yeah so that's very nice yeah
that's sweet yeah but it is it is fun to
watch it's special I mean what they do
on the offensive side of the football
and when they play that way where they
jump out in front of you like last night
that's the one thing that they've shown
and I think like we all worry about
their defense right and I understand it
the defense is not good it certainly has
some issues but I think the other thing
like their corners hanging on AG
Greene's neck during routes and it not
being good its they hold on every play
lot purpose especially 22 Orlando
Scandrick yeah they hold every play and
they go you're not gonna call it every
time right
yeah but but they're big thing too is
playing from a head
they have playmakers on the defensive
side of the ball we've talked about like
D Ford and Jones they can they can make
a few plays to change the football game
if they can get Eric Barry out there it
could be a lot like we saw two years ago
when they were the number two seed in
the AFC playoffs where yeah the defense
statistical he's not one of the best in
football but they create a lot of
turnovers a lot of pick sixes and when
they play in front because they do so
many different things on the defensive
side of the ball and you go okay damn
we're behind we got to throw the
football they do a lot of different
stuff on the back end that's going to
confuse a quarterback and an offensive
play call or to a degree and they put
the pressure on you and that's why yes
their defense is the worst in football
yeah but I don't know if it's really the
worst you know you gotta you gotta
remember this when teams are playing the
Kansas City Chiefs won they're coming
from behind so they're gonna put up
stats and the defense is gonna go we're
up by 21 we're not gonna play man-to-man
in your face until you have a 70 yard
bomb I'm waiting for the stat to go the
Chiefs are actually a top 10 run defense
I wonder why yeah right because the
other team has to throw at 60 times to
keep up with patches yeah you have to
take that into account I pee they do lie
exactly right added to the fact right
that when you play the Patriot I mean
the play the Chiefs you go huh we're
gonna have to push the envelope on the
offensive side of the ball today to keep
pace so all those things skew the stats
to a degree there are some redeeming
qualities about their defense and man
the way that game started last night who
you knew it was trouble for the bangles
and then it was over once you do the
pick so that's the Andy Reid I've always
wanted
it's the quarterback I've always wanted
you have an eight-year-old and on the
game last night they showed a clip of
Patrick mahomes at 8 years old yeah
throwing a basketball three-quarters of
a court on line right and drilling it
yeah
number one right could Phillip do that
right I think he could I think Phillip
could get it there yes I do
yes I do do you think you could have
done that oh no it was it was still very
impressive he's a special he's a special
hand-eye Talent I keep watching him Sims
and going maybe this is the week when he
comes back to Norman it's not gonna
happen I go no this is the normal it is
the normal man he's got a chance to
break Peyton Manning single-season
touchdown record and you're one of it
starter as a career which is also just
shows you how skewed the stats are this
day and age okay it's just a different
world I mean did you see the graphic
they put up last night about it he has
six consecutive 300 yard games and Elwes
like longest was three right RINO's
longest was exactly right so it just
shows you the 300-yard passing game this
day and age is like the - it's like 180
to 200 back in the old days that's
really what it is but it's amazing you
know what yeah his 300 is so different
yeah it is it's not it's not a lot of BS
300 it's it strikes down the field and
every time Tariq he'll touch the ball
Tyreke he'll touch the ball one I think
Sims right yeah I know it hurts it hurts
everybody the truth hurts speaking of
the truth yes
also we got to get to the truth to
Patrick Peterson cuz my internet worked
here hopefully to report all right well
we just want to inform the people don't
we yeah so next year he gets 11 million
dollars 11 million dollar cap hit and
it's dead money is dead money you could
release them if you wanted to
but 1100 that is not bad for a point of
his career yeah you'd pay that so you
ever do that you're after that the dead
money if you want it's 13 million
dollars and the dead money six hundred
thirty four thousand so so he actually
has a perfect con he really he really
died for see him for a year yes and if
he does really well maybe you you know
okay right he's only gonna be twenty
nine right and then if it doesn't work
out and you're in a short window like
the Saints yeah where you're like I
don't know how much more time I have a
priests I'm not gonna keep this guy then
you cut them for six hundred grand I
would think the Saints are gonna be one
of the teams that are certainly gonna be
in play for him here and like you said
the Chiefs I think you've secretly
moogles will a team like Pittsburgh or
Houston or the Chargers come into the
mix here that'll be the good thing it
could be okay
speaking of the truth yeah there was a
moment on Sunday or Josh and I looked at
each other and we only heard something
it was a red alert it was a moment that
we knew was coming for a very long time
I didn't know where you were going we
batten down the hatches
right we called for backup right and we
said oh my god
it's happened
Blake bortles was bench and the only
thing that I wondered in my little
pea-brain little pea-brain was his sims
at home right now feeling happy feeling
sad or is he standing up on his couch
and going I told you so
give me all your truths what were you
doing I can't say I was shocked but not
shocked after he fumbled the second time
and I was keeping my eye on that game of
course cuz it was one of my favorite
games of the day really to watch and as
I was watching that you know my thoughts
about him already I can always tell when
he's not sure where the ball is gonna go
on a given day for the beginning of the
being of the game his first throw of the
game the ball comes out of it and he
anybody that's out there watch on TV or
watch on film whatever he hops around
I'll throw the ball and a hop like oh
gosh I hope it gets there oh I hope it's
good like when you bowl and you're
wanting it to curve you're like is that
kind of stuff exactly right where he
hopped so that's to me when I when I
start to see that Blake bortles I got oh
he has no idea where the balls going
today he's just hoping it goes where he
wants it to go and that's really been
the theme for the last three weeks is
that type of play so it started out like
that you know their offense was stagnant
then of course his turn to turnovers led
to ten points hit deep in his own zone
right and I thought man after he fell in
the second time I said man they are they
don't they won't pull him out they'll
probably let him go at least another
series or two and I looked up and I was
like oh my gosh number six is in the
game and there you had it Cody Cody
Kessler so so where do you want to start
I don't think this has been your ship
well I mean it's my ship first of all I
mean if I'm gonna just take cheap shots
that everybody I'm gonna go where are
you people where is everybody that
wanted to tell me a black blake bortles
winning the AFC divisional game in
Pittsburgh and playing great in New
England and playing great in week two of
New England this year and I just it's
been four weeks in a row of horrible
plan I don't hear anybody ever come to
me and go all the haters of the
Twitterverse and Instagram I'll hear
anybody go damn Chris you know what
we're wrong
we were wrong you were right sorry man
because I know I do that all the time
when I'm wrong I say I self Scout myself
I get out there I just want some of the
apologies that's what I want and then my
other thing went to anger you know I
went to anger because I went to anger
because I wanted to be like [ __ ]
Jacksonville what were you thinking with
this what did you think was going to
happen you did this yeah you did this
this is your fault you made this bed
deal with it you said to us in the off
season he's five he's a good personality
everyone out there is hating on him
right this is all over the top we
trusted he's a great leader right I mean
they never talk about his play that's
the thing that you just have to read
between the tea leaves to go and go well
the team doesn't really think he's good
they say everything they avoid all
conversation about his play on the field
it's always something else I he take a
hit for him he's great in the locker
room I like when he runs into people
remember there was a whole article about
him running people over yes so you would
like an apology you're you are upset at
Jacksonville I am a set of judge because
their window is a closing right we're
seeing it on the defensive side of the
ball because it's funny when you look it
up and you go they did allow 20 points
okay Houston scored a field goal because
they got the ball in Jacksonville 36 off
the board all right and then as you said
they got the ball Jacksonville's 12
which led to a touchdown
yes their only other touchdown they
started at the 40 which I can pretty
much guarantee yeah Jacksonville did
nothing on offense before that drive and
then punted it to the 40 exactly right
that was that was the game and
Jacksonville's defense was phenomenal in
the football game I don't know what
other way to say it but when you got to
play beyond the field all game long
and the pressures on you every week to
win the football game and I know they
haven't been at their best the last few
weeks but last week they hung in there
with Dallas for a long time you know
there's just when the offense is
constantly going three and out six and
out three and out yeah I don't care who
you are the 85 Bears would have had a
hard time being the 85 Bears if that was
the case you know it's just too tough
and it's unfortunate because like we've
said this is one of the best teams in
football and fournette getting hurt for
not getting hurt and then losing
cam Robinson on the left tackle at Sims
the Jaguars were undefeated when for net
didn't play last year oh I know that's
like mortals was a better quarterback
when for net didn't play I thought they
were better without for net yeah they're
not because for net is a sledgehammer
and it's a there's no value you could
put on a guy again where it's first and
ten and there's nothing nowhere to go
or nothing to do and he could still run
for three and four yards and keep you in
second and six and then Blake bortles
can throw is running back screen or a
shallow cross or throw the guy in the
flat off the bootleg and those are the
things that aren't there now because
there's no run game
Doug maroon told reporters right that he
is not going to announce his quarterback
until he talks to Blake and Cody Kessler
okay what do you think he's gonna do I
think starting in London bortles plays
well in London man I feel like a that
London will play a role in this like he
might might chicken out a little bit and
go man Cody Kessler Eagles defense weird
week of preparation we're going to
London
maybe I just keep it the same for one
more week and if he and he plays bad
again we got to buy week after and then
we reassess from there yeah I mean he
literally came out and said the thought
process was I can't take all 11 out like
all the 11 of the offensive guys he's
upset they all offense and that was his
excuse me but I'm trying to motivate him
but I want to do something that's
proactive I don't want to just [ __ ] on
bortles Vick I have a list of the left
co5 yep the left go five that I believe
the Jaguars should look into maybe
getting share salvage this season that
could somehow come in and for net comes
back after this game and the buy which I
think they've been pretty much clearly
saying right I hope so for my fantasy
team I think so but the guys that I
think they should call and you tell me
the viability okay number one Robert
Griffin the third yeah we saw what he
did in preseason we saw how he looked
with the Baltimore Ravens he has the
mobility that can make that offense work
all of his passes were looking crisp
super tight all across the middle
definitely and I think he'd work well
with that team yeah do you think the
Ravens with Lamar Jackson getting a lot
of snaps I'd be willing to trade him for
a second third round pick I don't I
don't mmm I don't think so I think it
would have to be the kind of trade that
would blow them out of the water maybe a
second-round pick if they dry and they
said we'll send you a second-round pick
rg3
then they might think about it I just
don't know if they'd be willing to part
ways with that maybe it's maybe a pass
rush but you always Dante Fowler I mean
yeah but you also got to think you're
right even have to be something along
that that type of line with it but yeah
you also gotta remember the Baltimore
Ravens I don't think they trust Lamar
Jackson to be the quarterback of their
football team if Joe Flacco gets hurt so
that's why RG three is there and that's
the issue as everyone's gonna notice I
have a lot of names to pick yeah your
names are good keep on it you think that
especially after we saw Nick Foles step
up right of the Eagles a carry them
right there the teams that our actual
Super Bowl champions are not gonna be
willing to get rid of their backup and
they're the teams that have the good
backups right now like Nick Foles right
let's go there yeah if they called up
the Eagles and said we're gonna give you
a draft pick for Nick Foles and Carlos
hight who we're gonna get Carlos hight
and we're gonna flip them and give them
to you and I know you think the Eagles
need a running back they do with the
Eagles trade nick foles for a
second-round pick and Carlos Hyde I
think there'd be a chance they would I
do yes I think they would have enough
faith ago okay this is a big enough deal
to change around our football team not
only for this year but for a year or two
after this yeah and Nate's son Feld who
they've spoken highly of playdoh they
might play that's roll the dice on this
one and go alright we'll roll the dice
this year we don't think we were the
drag Wars would you want Nick Foles
would he'd help that team out a lot he
done he would definitely help them out
yes okay there's no question okay this
is one that I don't think well about
this one Teddy Bridgewater yeah he was
already picked up traded for from the
Saints right to get from the Jets do you
see no I
okay no because I love taste some I know
you do but there's a reason they traded
for Teddy Bridgewater because they saw
enough throwing or non throwing you from
Taysom Hill and training camp to go he's
not
ready to be our backup yet I think he's
the future guy that they're they're
grooming but he's still he stole this
running back / I'm learning how to throw
and be a quarter right return right
beast he's like it's incredible he's
like a more athletic Tim Tebow
but that's why I'd like Sean Payton to
only run that offense
I don't need why I say Wildcat I just
see that yeah
but it's funny it's another team that's
in the Superbowl window faculty or the
Ravens and Saints in that window and the
Eagles really and they're not gonna give
up their backup this is another team
that's kind of in the window yeah and a
lot of people are gonna say that guy is
not a real guy
the Chargers yeah I know Geno Smith
right who's been very good his whole
career and was on a [ __ ] Jets team and
nobody gave him credit for okay and then
came in last year for Eli Manning and
played one of the best games of the year
at quarterback for the Giants
put on the Raiders - and against the
Raiders yes that was he and he played
well I know Smith how much better is
Geno Smith and Blake bortles I mean like
yours I don't know what else to say I
mean yes he can drop back and throw the
football where he wants to when he wants
to on time but you don't think is the
Chargers if they lose Phillip Rivers
still have a chance with Geno Smith
exactly I know people are going oh
that's crazy no Geno Smith can sit back
there and die some people up in that
offense I'm not saying these Phillip
Rivers but all you got to do again is
look at the first two drives of Cody
Kessler see what people don't even
realize is what Jacksonville is not even
doing they don't even realize what
they're missing in their offense because
plays camp certain plays can't be called
with Blake bortles cuz he can't get the
ball out of his hand crisp Kruk wicking
up and crisp enough sometimes for the
shorter you know more dissecting passing
rats to be surgical in his own coverage
he can't do that so you know there it
was the first drive I think they ended
up going three and out or six and out
but then the next drive it was kind of
quick passing game precision Bam Bam Bam
and then he rolls out to the right and
through you know a nice little law
passed the Yeldon who made a great catch
in the end zone but that's what I mean I
don't think people are realizing what
they're missing in that Jacksonville
offense I think think people think are
they're calling these plays because this
is what they really want to call right
there they don't realize that there
having to call these plays that's what
I've been trying to tell people my last
thing is I was trying to look around the
league and look at all the backups and I
I found a guy on a team right now
yeah his last four games he's gotten in
six touchdowns one interception for the
year the last real fool I guess
11 games he's played 16 touchdowns four
interceptions and I think he's really
good and I would just ask anyone and
he's super mobile yes sponsored by a
certain Nike yeah he's not a backup it's
Colin Capra there's zero chance they're
gonna sign them zero I mean two things
but my thing is is if you're really
trying to win you gotta bring them in if
you're really trying to win you gotta
bring cap in a phrase like that if
you're trying to win you bring cap in
yeah if you're not then you need to make
a trade because who's the guy that just
got cut by the Broncos Paxton Lynch
Paxton Lynch ain't gonna be the guy no
Romo ain't coming out of the booth other
than maybe Matt Simms
there's nobody on the street right now
that I'm gonna go you know what they're
better than Cody Kessler or Blake
bortles
right but there's one free agent
available that might be yeah and if you
don't bring them in you ain't trying to
win no III hear ya you know I'll play
devil's advocate okay he we know I'm on
your side with this Colin Kaepernick's
been [ __ ] over I don't know what to
say
he's been still in shape I do think he's
still in shape now being able to step in
after not playing a year and a half of
football will not be easy so I don't
think that's gonna like Jackson was
gonna look at that go oh we want that
guy we need they're gonna look and we
need somebody that can contribute right
away and as you and I both know NFL
coaches are extremely conservative and
they have a hard time going let's roll
the dice on the guy that hasn't played
in two years so now the reso now him
being held out will is not gonna be used
to get exactly the other thing I would
say which is again so screwed up that is
his style something that would fit oh
it's perfection
Ciao Bella that's how well Kaepernick
what's I mean boo
system play-action passes Oh nothing's
open runaround I mean come on yeah he
would be phenomenal let alone that he
can really throw the ball when he is
throwing it at his best he could
actually throw it to DJ charkh deep I
mean he could throw it as good as I mean
we've seen we have enough evidence to go
when contact Kaepernick has an offense
and a little coaching his physical
ability can be special I mean he could
throw balls that I would go man there's
not a lot of quarterbacks in the league
that can throw that ball that right
there and there's not a lot of
quarterbacks they're gonna turn the
corner like he just did in the running
game yeah so I hear you but the other
thing we have to blame to this to the
region of the country okay at the same
point and you were gonna say that
I know because Carolina Panthers
designed their order and I know he's not
the quarterback though that's that was a
minor is right out there with Florida
you're right you're right I get you it's
just still not the quarterback so it
sounds polarizing walls and yeah it's
very troubling added to the fact that
Tom Coughlin we know that I know yeah
but like I tell you as an army guy he's
a freakin West Point army guy and then
he should have the accountability to
look in the mirror and go what is my
duty
he should I have an ability to get a
quarterback in the offseason and not be
held hostage by this idea him and Dave
Caldwell
like this is why I'm mad at Jacksonville
you know I like Jacksonville this is
where this all started because I love
watching Jacksonville play and there's
this been this one issue at the one
position that's kind of important for
the last three years and I've been
trying to tell people that they're the
best team in football so there's a part
of me now that wants to go eat at
Jacksonville screw you
cuddle up and spoon next to Blake
bortles pull up the covers and get cozy
cuz this is the bed you made remember
when you offered him a two-year 36
million dollar contract and you were you
were what you were you were gonna go me
against yourself what do I want to say
there you know they were they were you
know while they were negotiating ago she
thank you is the word they were
negotiating against themselves
who's out there offering dated minds no
one no hello we'll get
we'd know who's offering 10 billion no
what no no we'll give them 18 who's
offering 5 million no what no one will
give them a kid I mean that's what they
did so there's like a part of me that
just wants to go eating a Jacksonville
this is what you deserve your team could
have got on the Super Bowl this year and
you wanted to you know ride the ship
again I don't know I don't know what to
say it makes me angry though because I
do like them I have mad crushes on them
you know that the only other names were
made by Rod Taylor Taylor that is the
one that makes sense the most right when
we looked at it because he's definitely
not gonna be replacing like Baker
Mayfield they're not on the Super Bowl
Super Bowl team right and they had John
Stanton and they have Drew Stanton who's
a solid number two number three right so
you could go okay like they why would
tie-rod work in Jacksonville when it
wasn't working in Cleveland yeah it's
not that it's gonna be groundbreaking
but again I could promise you tie rod
tie rod and his whole life hasn't thrown
as many screwballs as Blake bortles did
in the first quarter of that game
yesterday when I say screw balls I mean
like you know again people are gonna
look at like little plays like keel and
coal over the middle early on where you
know it was like a five yard pass and he
was right there and they're gonna go oh
well he should have caught that because
he got two hands out yeah you should
have caught it sure he's an NFL receiver
but I'd also say the guy was sitting
there and it was like a rocket ball
wobbler down by his knees like you
couldn't make it any harder on the guy
to catch the football and that again
goes into it so I'll Cody Kessler throw
like 20 of those and they never dropped
them because it was a spiral and it was
where it was supposed to be and those
are the little things again that people
were missing we've gotten to the point
with Blake bortles
where he hits a 5-yard shallow and we go
huh see he could play quarterback yeah
look at Sukkot see through a shallow
cross and the guy ran for 40 Sims
doesn't know what he's talking about and
I'm just trying to give everybody a
reality the situation that's what we've
come to
we've gone huh look at that he threw the
bootleg guy in the flat for 10 yards he
could play quarterback what I don't
understand is they can watch Patrick
mahomes and understand what greatness is
yeah and then they watch the other side
and make excuses the funny thing is you
get paid based on like clicks yeah you
know what I mean yeah it's it's only
true observation but people want you to
be biased because it makes them feel
better
I've never understood right you're right
yeah like there's no advantage to you
like no we're doing exactly right nor do
I like listen to social media or like
get like involved with that conversation
to let it influence me so if you want to
argue about whether or not
Odell is immature or a team leader right
if you want to argue about Tyree kill
being number one yeah if you want about
that Michael Kemosabe in top ten those
are great cars you're great
conversations but the Blake bortles one
has always been so black and white and I
have never understood how anyone could
make it gray no I don't I really think a
lot of it is just because he's such a
good guy I get it I know and I think
that's part of the backlash you brought
up Michael Thomas yeah if there's one
team so we have a new Falcons and it's
the Saints which is incredible I've
picked to go to the Super Bowl who you
were a head of the Saints last year have
win in the south before anybody did but
I'm noticing something yeah you are
lower on camara than most people right
you are lower on mike thomas thomas than
most PBS and you are definitely lower on
drew brees than most people right and
it's not because you don't like the
Saints it's because you're so darn high
on Sean Payton yes and what what I would
like you to do for the people out there
and even Michael Thomas who responds to
tweets apparently right and people that
when you don't put them on the list it's
it's because you believe that Sean
Payton puts people in a position to
succeed is that better than almost any
other coach in the NFL right and if you
could explain to people without even
having to look up numbers yeah what what
is it about Sean Payton that other
coaches don't do and what is it about
Sean Payton that truly in your mind
makes him a top-five play caller in the
history of the NFL right like you do you
really put him up there with the bill
Walsh's without a doubt do you really
put him up there with like the great
offenses of all time or Coryell you just
name it yeah he's he's surpassed like
he's surpassed
all of them except for maybe okay a bill
wash okay that's that's this really
special guy but other than that and Sean
Payton with all that he's done
offensively for that New Orleans Saints
football team all right
so first of all let's just take what we
saw yesterday okay just think about all
the things he does to give it give us a
team an advantage okay he plays in that
game they go for it on fourth down on
the first drive of the football game
four times four times and but why does
that make him a good coach well it makes
them a good coach because it's again
aggressiveness it keeps them in control
of things
their offense starts to go damn okay
coaches he's got confidence that we can
continue to do that and they were good
play calls they were extremely creative
play calls except for the one pitch out
but I think I might get it to except
they just got too close to each other
and taste some Hill misses it
but it's aggressive play calling like
that keeping a Baltimore Ravens defense
out on the field which is not used to
it's used to get off the field let's go
it over there and rest so we can be back
a hundred percent yeah kick some butt
again you change the dynamic of the
football game right off the bat with
little stuff like that now let's talk
about the taste some Hill part oh no
they've played to outside road games
this year on the first drive of both of
those games he's called Taysom Hill fake
punts okay and they got first downs both
of those times and that's him so that's
him that's totally head coach stuff head
coach is the guy that makes those plays
and decisions he goes in during the week
and goes what he might ask the special
teams coach on a Monday or Tuesday what
do you think or maybe two or three fake
special teams plays we could get away
with this week how do you think the rest
of the NFL talks about Sean Payton I
think a lot like I do in fact I know
they do I mean Sean okay so then like
you know Kyle Shanahan just Kyle
Shanahan think about Sean Payton Kyle
Shanahan I bet you well I know this
watches Sean Payton's tape every week
just to see let me just see what he's
doing
let me see if I could steal a few ideas
he's a he's a staple for a lot of OU
season football because they want to go
what's the new screen pay what's the new
play-action pass he's running you know
what's what did he do on he ran all
these fourth downs let me go see what he
did on these fourth downs to go back and
because so I can maybe use one or steal
one when I have a fourth and short but
ok it's it's it's more
even that was Sean Payton it's the
toughness of his football team this team
went from a oh we're gonna be five five
thousand yards a year with Drew Brees
and we're gonna throw the ball all over
the lot too man Drew's getting up there
a little bit I don't know if he can
carry us with 5,000 anymore let's become
a power running team and Smash Mouth
football you know who's one of the best
running teams in football the last two
years did New Orleans Saints they never
they never lose patience with it they
run the ball and just about everybody
we're seeing um okay that also seems
like he has complete control of this
franchise he does for the most part yeah
I mean it's him and Mickey Loomis or
making player decisions together
but yeah how can you not trust them cuz
it's funny because it seems like you
everyone focuses on the Saints that you
underrate right but really what you're
saying is no you're all underrating Sean
Payton of course they are now again okay
so there's that
you know the run game you forget the
play get the play design which is like
we talked about this a few weeks ago
Sean Payton is without a doubt one of
the best run game designers in football
he is either one two or three in the
screen game it's either him McDaniels or
McVeigh and then play-action passes down
the field for shots I would say it's
Kyle Shanahan one and Sean Payton two
and then maybe McVeigh three it's very
close there either way so if we put Sean
McVeigh Kyle Shannon Josh McDaniels I'm
even gonna throw in Andy Reid Doug
Peterson all these guys in a room Sean
McVeigh and I said which one of you guys
do you all look at and go man they got
some dynamic stuff they're probably
looking at what McVeigh and Peyton yeah
I mean they're all gonna go he does
things in his offense that he likes they
have all their they're all little
strengths but I think Sean Payton really
has no weakness to his overall offensive
game planning let's just talk about
let's just talk about the
record-breaking game for Drew Brees a
few weeks ago I guess Peyton Manning's
record I'm not hating on Drew Brees
he's one of the 10 best quarterbacks in
the history of football you know maybe I
say he's 12 he's right around there but
you know still incredible which I know
well that a play quarterback but let's
think about how all right so he breaks
the record
on a great play design with a wide open
with a wide open who was that Cameron
Meredith on that one no it was not it
was who was it the other kid Trey Kwon
symmetric ones so Trey Kwon psmith for a
wide-open 62-yard touchdown pass where
nobody's in the screen the ball went
like 20 yards let alone earlier in the
game to help those yards out we saw what
a Mark Ingram ski 28 yard what down to
the one-yard line
scream pass it's always plays like that
and Michael Thomas is a really good
football player but again how can
anybody watch yesterday and go Michael
Thomas is on a level of some of the
other guys that I put in front of him I
mean he's not like here in a double move
out and up which was called by Sean
Payton in the huddle okay and it was set
up and drew threw the ball perfect but
other than that what was there that
makes everybody go oh wow it's so
dynamic and special after the catch sure
he's just blowing by people deep and
they have to put another guy on him so
it's not about a disrespect for anybody
else Michael Thomas is really good I
just don't think he's one of the 10 best
in football he has a definite role
within that offense and Sean Payton
knows how to use him within that role
that's what he is he's better and
Marques Colston that's what he is for
them back shoulder catches work the
middle of the field catch a slant down
in the ground in the v endzone for a
touchdown catch those tough footballs
that keep the drives moving I spit there
there's a lot but yes that's why I look
at Sean Payton I don't know if that was
good enough for you it was perfect about
a how about an onside kick to start the
second half of a Super Bowl that
nobody's ever done in the history of the
sport
how about that I mean that's the part of
Sean Payton that all those other
offensive coordinators that I mentioned
I see it sometimes from Sean McVeigh but
Sean Payton has the most guts Sean
Payton is and you said this when we were
talking on OCS a few weeks ago he dials
up the biggest oh crap place on a
regular basis to really catch you yeah
and he has no fear and Sean Payton to me
is a defensive coaches mindset with the
brains of an offensive court thank you
that's what it feels what did they do
they went in to Baltimore yesterday and
said no they said we're Baltimore screw
Baltimore will
we'll show you how to run and PI tough
football they out Baltimore Baltimore in
Baltimore yeah nobody does that
do you read his postgame press
conference it's all it was about
Baltimore at home controlling the clock
all these numbers that lead to more win
when Baltimore yeah he stopped them all
yesterday and in the fact that Baltimore
got the 14-point swing or the 10-point
swing and a half time where they scored
got the ball back and scored again they
went up 17 to 7 I was like oh yeah
Baltimore did exactly what they need to
do to win this game right and the Saints
came out and it was just bang bang bang
tasty mils of weapon by the way you're
now one-on-one on predictions Blake
bortles will be starting against the
Eagles but he will be quote on a pitch
count or they're gonna they're gonna
short leash short leash yes
what does I'm one-on-one what was my
other what was that wrong oh you're one
for one all one for one sorry uh and
Tyrann Mathieu comes out and says hey
Patrick Peterson come to Houston oh that
would be a spot like I said they could
really use him a man honey badger is
balling but I want to go off of what I'm
notice that explained Shawn pain enough
you nailed it alright this is my thing
that I'm seeing with the Saints yeah
there are certain seasons when something
begins to brew right that we don't have
control over Matt Ryan's MVP season we
were singing it from the beginning
Peyton Manning's 50 touchdown season it
was just there
the Adrian Peterson 2000 yard season we
knew it in week four and it kept on go
right there is a storyline brewing right
now that you can all think that the MVPs
wide open I'm telling you right now
Patrick mahomes is not winning the MVP
because the cosmic alignment has begun
the Illuminati has sent in their vote
and Drew Brees is winning MVP it's
aligning Drew Brees national football
game Monday Night Football breaks Brett
Favre and Peyton Manning's record right
has the ultimate father moment with his
kids while he's miked up and retires the
ball on the field to the
white gloved hands of Dave Baker right
then in the game in which he scores his
500th touchdown he also beats the one
team that he had never beaten with his
history of his career that's like one of
the coolest stats ever because you got
to be on two teams for it to have pretty
cool so again being up there with Peyton
Manning and Brett Favre both guys with
some MVPs in their hardware Alex yeah he
also gave us the moment against Atlanta
his archrival the backwards spin dive
for a touchdown so that you could really
go awesome buddies doing everything
right but you know how I know that the
stars have aligned because for the first
time in his NFL career regular season
postseason after 245 kicks Justin Tucker
missed an extra point and more
importantly if you saw the Bulge of his
eyes some people said it was like he saw
a ghost it's exactly what he saw he saw
the spirit following Drew Brees
push that ball a little bit to the right
that wasn't the wind that was the
football gods going
sorry JT H Drew Brees time miss we are
in the midst of the Drew Brees MVP
season yeah they will get the to seed in
the NFC they will they will cruise with
this team they have a very tough
schedule coming up
but the Drew Brees MVP season is here
just when weird stuff happens all year
just remember it's cosmic and we don't
have any control and it's the one thing
missing from his resume yeah and it's
here yeah I'm gonna control no it does
seem like a lot of stars are aligning
for that it's a shame because what's
gonna happen eventually they're gonna go
oh mahomes he's got Tyree kill he's got
Kelsey he's got Han he's young he's got
years here oh I love that oh yeah yeah
cuz you know in 20 years we're gonna
look back and go we're gonna remember
who was second place in any MV
yeah we don't remember well it's
insulting when they say it would be a
shame either way he's having a great
year and there's no doubt about that but
he's he would not you know of course not
be anywhere in the conversation for MVP
a football for me at this point well I
know that it's really good but I mean
well you can't be the MVP of football
when you're not even the focal point of
your own offense I mean that's like is
that a sign I don't know what else to
say if you're not the focal point of
your own offense and they go no our
running game and our linemen are then I
don't think you should automatically be
like cancelled out there but we have a
lot of time left and maybe he continues
to kick ass here so right now it's made
about the play that always gets made
about what left go completion percentage
yes yeah well you know who was the
number one rated quarterback in football
last year was who was it do you remember
who the number one was because I could
tell you ain't the number one
quarterback in football Sam Bradford
Alex Smith oh all right that tells you
completion percentage is valued too
highly on the quarterback rating scale
yeah it means nothing
the quarterback rating scale is stupid
because of that right now Drew Brees is
quarterback rating is a hundred and
twenty one point six for the year right
13 touchdowns zero interceptions and
what no one ever talks about with Drew
Brees is he arguably has the best
offensive line the NFL after the games
using a hater again it's okay what's
gonna be funny too is I've where they
get to the playoffs
well I chickened out about putting the
Chargers in the Super Bowl I think I
have them losing to the Steelers in the
NFC but that would be a really amazing
superb All Saints chargers right because
Phillip Rivers you can inject him in the
MVP conversation right now sure cuz he's
doing some special things as well
Phillip Rivers right now over 2000
passing yards 17 touchdowns three
interceptions with a 117 point eight
quarterback rating and just so you know
Patrick mahomes 2,200 passing yards 22
touchdowns five interceptions a hundred
and fourteen completion percentage is
too much of an issue for this whole
rating thing though it really is I don't
even know why it's a factor well it
shouldn't it should be completion per
attempt that's what it should really yes
but you did tech you did text me after
the games and you said you can write it
in ink you can book it
the first two seeds for the NFC are
ready to go
it is Rams and Saints yeah you're you're
ready to go already week seven they're
the top two seats I think so I don't see
how it'll fall off I really don't I
think the the Saints have already gone
through the rough patch of their year as
far as no I'm just saying another
schedule I'm just saying the way they
played they played Oh
aspiring football the first three or
four weeks and ended up three and one
right what we have talked about where we
just go that's when you know you're a
good team yeah when you don't play good
and you look up and you go well we're
three and one and we haven't even played
good yet yeah it is crazy though I will
say this about their schedule yeah at
Minnesota right and then home against
the Rams but here the tough teams and
they get them at home they get the Rams
at home they get the Eagles at home they
get the Steelers at home it's big all
the other teams they play they got to go
on the road in Minnesota on the road of
Cincinnati which doesn't look as tough
anymore right on the road of Dallas and
then the rest of divisional games but
the tough teams they get at home tough
teams and like two of those three you
don't want to really play up there and
their stadiums and that's not where New
Orleans and Drew Brees have been at
their best in those outside elements and
you have chiefs and Patriots locked in
the AFC I think so are there any other
teams that you would be willing to lock
right now for the playoffs I mean I know
you want to say the Chargers be here a
little bit concerned that's my top five
I think I think the Chargers would I
feel pretty good about saying the
Chargers are gonna be a playoff football
I can't wait till Joey Bosa comes back
yeah I know my top five in football
right now is Rams number one right hatre
it's number two Chiefs number three
Saints number four Chargers number five
that's my top five okay let's yeah would
you switch any of those or am I missing
anybody I don't have the Ravens right
there right now I think they're still
missing something creative he's a
prisoner of the moment like I think
calling me a prisoner of the month well
no I just no I just I think I would put
the chief stew in the Patriots three
even though the bait I know they beat
them but you know okay they beat them in
New England they didn't play their best
game yeah it's you know I mean who's to
say I would also say it's the same it's
it's close right well they have the
tiebreaker just goes to the playoffs I
feel good about the Patriots yeah sure
my other thing would
I like Bell Belichick having game tape
of you against my defense sure like oh I
get like Bill Belichick versus team he's
already faced yeah it's not the first
time no I know I know it's gonna be
different with can also like and also
like this whole thing about treating the
Patriots like their equal is [ __ ]
the Patriots are not equal their
nutrients are better than everybody else
yeah in almost every faction right and
if we're gonna into a one-game situation
that's the reason that Eagles Super Bowl
felt so good right because the Patriots
are not a normal French guys and the
rest of these teams are and if Patrick
mahomes played out of his mind to get
themselves back into that game and was
down double digits and somehow came back
then I'm gonna take the team that
survived it and had them in that
position to begin with yeah it took you
a tyree kill holy crap what the hell did
we just allow happen for you to beat
them right and I know the Chiefs are
really good yeah no I I get you I don't
think there's anything wrong with you
lot of rams are number one Rams are
definitely number one I don't know I
guess two three and four would all be I
can make a case for all that's right I
would say the Patriots are the fourth in
the NFL no I could say you can make them
two three or four but no I would
probably I think if you can put a gun to
my head I would probably make the
Patriots to your right Chiefs three
Saints for Chargers fine yeah so you're
just your poseur now something around
there yes yeah by the way the gun to my
head yeah you like that no I mean it's I
mean you didn't invent it I know I just
think it's a really drastic thing to go
to in a conversation well just like you
know when I have to make a decision
right here but like you have to make a
decision when the waiter comes I know
there's not a gun to my head I can be I
come back in a minute
oh not quite sure the other night I was
out with unum and though she kept going
back and forth and I go I'd like this
what are you half and she goes suffer
that yeah but yeah gun in my head really
unnecessary yeah that's all right
yeah you could say the deadline is in
five seconds isn't it funny also do this
to humans in your life when something's
happening randomly countdown to three
and watch them act like those numbers
matter like I know it's a thing people
do to children or it's like get off the
chair get off
three two and then they move but do it
to adults yeah
I do it all the time you really yes but
they don't realize that I'm messing with
them I just go get off the chair and I
go Philip get off the chair do I have to
ask you again and then he doesn't do
anything you know okay so do you want me
to make you cry oh gosh
no but seriously if you're like if like
who you gonna pick my head and then you
go three two they go uh uh it's like you
don't have to respond to my numbers okay
anyway what was your top five again Rams
my top five was Rams Patriots Chiefs
Saints Chargers and then someone on
Twitter was like well what happens next
week if the Vikings beat the Saints and
I responded then I'll probably change my
list that's how this works and he goes
oh didn't really think that one through
I go yeah I think I might actually make
the chief for behind the same yeah you
say well you sick oh yeah I think if you
gave me one game against the those two
against each other
mmm that'd be tough it would be a really
yes it'd be fun all right so we already
did it's funny I had in this dock for
what we're gonna do
who was going to land Patrick Peterson
yes the Arizona Cardinals should have a
yard sale and then that came out today
do you think that the pass rusher could
be up as well Chandler Jones yeah I I
wouldn't think so like are we talking
full-fledged fire say I don't think so I
mean he is their best defensive player
he fits their scheme he is in the prime
of his career III don't think they would
go that far
okay yeah I think like David Johnson and
Chandler Jones David Johnson I think
they're the only two that are for sure
that the Eagles call up and somehow get
David Jones no I don't think you know
Patrick Peterson's for sale can they
call up and go no we'll give you a
second-round pick I don't leave it good
no
would you give up a first-round pick for
David Johnson yeah do you think the
Cardinals would take it no I don't know
if they would for your own theory
they're you know they're gonna go well
no we know we have one of the best backs
in football we know it's not our best
well we got them in the fourth round or
the third round we could probably do it
again
you know you can't sorry is it that good
he is that good
yes offence was just trash that's trash
which is another thing like no offense
to Mike McCoy but offense to Mike McCoy
how do we keep giving jobs to people
that are getting fired afternoon how do
you go to Denver get fired after a year
and then a new coach starts in Arizona I
guess my thing is if I was starting a
company I'm definitely not taking people
that are being fired for not doing good
jobs at their company right or I'm gonna
try and peel away people that are up in
commerce or that have been doing a good
job but if you've been fired for two
jobs in the last 18 months I'm not going
that's the guy that I'm gonna stake my
reputation or no wow is that possible
because it's the NFL and it's full of
that and we have to stop putting these
people on pedestals because they have a
nice fancy emblem on their business card
it's it's they know it's relationships
he listens to the guy when he gives them
the interview the guy makes up some bull
crap excuses of why I didn't work in the
last place and the guy like somebody
goes I'll buy it yep you're hired
yeah okay no you have to evaluate like
Oh Bill Musgrave got fired from Oakland
well let me watch their offense oh [ __ ]
number six in football you know that was
always well Hiram the fat most
fascinating thing about the Dan Quinn
hire was when you said the one guy that
always gave him trouble was Kyle
Shanahan and he said when I get the job
in Atlanta yeah because you always
kicked my ass I want you to be my OC
right that's the stuff I'm looking for
exactly I'm not looking for me and him
one time at combine had a few beers
together I like working with it right
where they trust me I like working with
people that I don't really like working
with it's it does that make sense yeah
but it's a bull a big thing in the NFL
culture with coaches is trust and yes
trust and yes trust I trust the shock
gonna talk [ __ ] behind my back and I
like when he says yes to anything I say
exactly right um do you think Byron
Leftwich is gonna be a good coordinator
I Bruce Arians was like that's my guy I
mean I love B and B loves football
that's what you call Byron yeah yeah
Byron's a good dude he really is and I
do think that he will have more to offer
as far as ideas are concerned because of
Ariens because of what he learned even
up in Pittsburgh a little bit as last
year vision
you know there'll be there'll be more he
can bring to the table especially with
like pass game schematics oh my gosh
well I mean and also having blade and
all that stuff I'm excited because I
can't believe Byron Leftwich is a
coordinator Eagles film yeah
my my fan base right now is going
through it and I'd like to say something
before you you share with me your heads
before the season I said I don't think
the egos are gonna make the playoffs I
think they're gonna be fighting for a
spot but it's gonna be really close and
the Eagles fanbase disowned me yeah they
yelled at me they called me an idiot how
could you not have the Super Bowl
champions on there overlooking the fact
that a number of Super Bowl champions
fall off the face of the earth
afterwards right and now that they're
three and four are freaking out
everything's in shambles what the hell's
going on so at first I told you they
weren't that good and you called me an
idiot now they're not that good and now
you're surprised and freaking out when I
already told you this I'm the only
Eagles fan that's gonna tell you come
down it's absolutely fine the Eagles
really aren't that bad in fact I would
argue they were up 17 nothing on the
Panthers they were up 17 3 on the Titans
they are doing well in games and then
something's happening at the end which
I'm hoping you're gonna explain to me
but they're beating these teams they
have the best quarterback in the NFC
East they have what they have what a
good offensive line that's still there
yeah I'd argue that they're wide
receiving core is right up there with
any team in the NFC East because the
Giants don't count because our
quarterback can't get it to them they
have the best tight end in the NFC East
they have the best offensive line in the
NFC East maybe other than the Cowboys
their linebackers are not bad their
secondaries an issue but I would also
say that they might have the best coach
in the NFC East right so when we're
freaking out right now
realize that the team that's ahead of
you is one win ahead in the win column
and are you really worried about
Washington long term are you really
worried about Alex Smith dicing up the
Eagles defense because I'm not because
watch them almost completely throw away
a 2210 lien of their own to a team that
legitimately can't throw the ball right
now so to all the Eagles fans that
called me an idiot when I said they
weren't that good and I'm now freaking
out when they're realizing they're not
that good let me be the eagle source to
tell you calm down the Eagles are still
likely going to win the division because
they have all those key pieces so relax
chill it's just and also like you won
the Super Bowl can you have some
perspective like you lost all those
players last year and somehow you had
faith but now we're gonna throw it all
away because Cam Newton came back and
won the game I never that's what I don't
understand right
what's wrong with the Eagles why is a
former MVP of the NFL not allowed to
engineer three good drives against the
defense this was not Kirk that uh let me
think this was not it was a really below
average score but this is not Derrick
Anderson you know this is Kant Newton
yeah sometimes great players make great
plays and get paid to yes yeah I know
it's just a real kick in the dick that
he got that fourth and ten at Torrey
Smith a weapon that I really think the
Eagles could use yeah I hear ya all
right that was my Eagles round that's a
good rant alright do you think it's you
know pumped the race Eagles fans this
ain't over by any stretch of the
imagination the NFC is wide open and the
teams you have in front of you are yes
the Washington Redskins who absolutely
fault Junior I've some good football
team the thing they have in their favor
is they have another little easy
schedule or stretch of schedule here to
where they can put themselves in a spot
and go ooh thanks bro I've heard this
lose any game no doubt about that yes I
get you wait until we get them on the
road look at them on the road yeah no I
mean their second half of their schedule
other than the next few weeks is not
they they got they got Giants Falcons
Bucks and then after that it gets real
for the Redskins it goes Texans Cowboys
Eagles Giants Jaguars Titans Eagles
welcome to Thunderdome yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying the Eagles right now or
want to know if they lost a few
divisional games Venom getting nervous
they get washing
in twice they get Dallas twice and they
get the Giants again you want to know
whether or not they went in division
those do it all right so when you all
start I want to start I'm just gonna ask
you questions yes ask me could I'd like
you to fill in the blank
yes how did they go from up 17 nothing
and the defense having maybe their best
performance of the year what the hell
happened in the fourth quarter I just
want to get right to the meat yeah the
fourth quarter okay I think was it
prevent defense it wasn't prevent
defense now you didn't challenge the
receivers on the outside very much so
guys like Jalen Mills and Darby started
to play seven eight yards off Jalen
Mills really was about eight nine yards
off and they started the game in Jam so
yeah they were up in their face more
okay but also I think what cam just said
is okay they're gonna have they're gonna
give me these throws they got to the
point in the game where they finally
said you know what we got to stop
looking for play design over the middle
of the field let's just take it out
there let's take a six yard throw out
there maybe he breaks the tackle we get
sticker to say because let's throw an
out route and get 12 yards he goes out
of bounds things like that so they
started to do those type of things
started playing a little soft and
coverage for sure
you know you get the McCaffrey out of
the backfield for a few yards in the
pass game all of those things you know
chances to get big sacks and the big guy
a quarterback he stands in there and
makes the rose and make plays so I think
where I look if there was another
quarterback back there
this game would have been over I did way
through the floor I could I would say
that - yeah it would I took a special
quarterback to do what was done
yesterday in that football game
especially in the wind and knowing
you're gonna have to throw that
yesterday in the northeast was made for
this is these are the days why we here
northeast football teams go size is
important to us at quarterback and hands
size is very important to throw in the
elements because you've got to be able
to throw through the wind like we saw
and we saw Sam darling miss some throws
into the wind there and throw some
battery Simpsons we saw Kirk Cousins
who's used to football Pierre just go up
the hell with it I'll throw it deep to
Thiele and I'll throw it deep this I
could throw spirals and cut right
Baldrick Robinson exactly right I could
throw a deep out to Devin Funchess for
15 yards right into the wind no problem
so
I think hey they got a little momentum
going they make it 17 to 6 ok 17 to 6
they put it together a really good drive
that was capped by the Curtis Samuel
reverse for the touchdown right great
play call right it was a great play call
there was a number of things that went
on there but then the next drive it goes
three passes in a row three and out who
the Eagles Eagles three pilots on that
well I don't like the that did not lose
the game the majority of these passes
down the stretch were completions and
the clock kept running but my big thing
is once again it's just the impatience
with the run game what again
I didn't chart these plays but my eye is
usually correct that when you guys run
up the middle you move the chains and
you move four or five six eight yards
now your running backs or an issue but
yeah I had an issue with them getting
away with getting away from that and
getting into this short Dinkin dunk pass
game to where now Carolina just rallied
and made tackles and you guys weren't
able to get first down you even said on
that final drive that ended up in the
turnover on down right that on that
second down second and 10 they get eight
yards and then for some reason abandon
the run after they had so much success
on the second down running yeah yeah
this is doing their down 21 to 17 right
so so let me show it second and ten on
the 22 Smallwood up the middle eight
yards third and two on Carolina's 14
with 37 second he does what incomplete
down the middle to Jeffrey was almost
intercept right which was a horrible
decision by Carson I can't defend him
there
Wendell Smallwood is open in the flat to
the left for an easy first down and
maybe more and then Nelson Aguilar is
open on the side he's looking to throw
to Alshon Jeffery it's a post right down
the middle and two under routes coming
the under routes they're for Nelson
Aguilar get the first down move on
continue to play yeah and you know
extend your downs and time to score a
touchdown here so there's the issue with
that but yeah it's 17 to 6 it's three
straight passes 1714 it's six straight
passes diesel six straight time I fasted
nine straight times once they went the
game with 272 six then you get the ball
back now you're down 21 to 17
yes and you don't run the ball again
until the pie you're just talking about
so that last won't run yeah was the only
run of the three drives in which Cam
Newton began to come yes it was it was
and I really think you're missing a big
part of your team by a course I think
the strength of your football team is up
the middle and being able to run through
there like Jason Peters it's he's on his
last leg he's a nominee if I'm the
Eagles and I see them not run behind
Kelsey Brooks Lane Johnson exactly I
don't know why you would ever run no and
I know Kelsey and Brooks are so good on
the inside and was Nueske's a good
little run blocker to to where and it
wasn't was new ski you say sumela who
did a good job when they ran behind 6ml
so you got those three those three guys
yes do that
but my big point would be in doing this
two is man it's a lot of work for your
offense it's a lot it's a lot of work
for Carson Wentz I mean you you watch
the game he's he's not throwing to
people that are necessarily wide open
it's urged 20 yards down the field with
a safety on us exactly right I mean it's
it's al Shawn Jeffery with a guy tightly
covered and he throws it up and puts it
high all shots a baller he's a baller
ball but he's a baller with a guy like
Carson Wentz because Carson goes oh we
only got the keyhole I gotta hit the
keyhole here I can hit it as long as I
throw in that keyhole you'll catch it
right now Sean just is like our I got it
so so you're still high on Wentz yes I'm
still high on Jeffery and what they can
do but it's work for your offense let me
look at your drives in the football game
think about your drive to start the game
I mean what was that 12 plays you missed
the field goal yeah the next drive is
seven plays 74 yards okay not bad I
could deal with that six plays 60 yards
for a field goal then it's set by the
way miss field goal was 15 plus 15 plays
so there's seven and the touchdown 17 99
yards right so that's that's that's too
much to ask of an offense and too much
of to ask of a quarterback to
consistently throw the ball in the
screws make the right decision stand in
the pocket every throw you guys are
really missing another playmaker in the
offense and that's where last year a JK
min to the fold and the run game came to
the ball this is why I want you to guys
run the ball up the middle because I
think if you can run the
up the middle you can stay in the
shotgun if you like but you could put
carson wentz underneath center and what
do we like out of those kind of
formations pi action passes what we see
New England are we not seeing a lot of
play action no especially not
traditional play action underneath the
center let me pull the guard let me get
nine yards deep and let's go for a 25
yard completion like you see the Rams
and the Niners and the Patriots and the
Saint and the Saints do every week you
have to have some of those plays that
make it easier on your life you also
think Corey Clements lost a mile per
hour
he definitely has it's just your running
backs don't get any more than what's
there to be had do you want to be my
notes I want to know how much of a
contender are the Panthers for real I
mean I've yeah I think the Panthers
they're not going anywhere
the Panthers again I would say I would
say they were not the better team on the
field yesterday okay just like I said
last week I think the Panthers were the
better team on the field against the
Redskins
so yeah the Panthers are forward to the
Redskins are forward to if you made me
rank those teams I'd go no the Panthers
are better than the Redskins right yeah
I mean they the Eagles are better than
both I do I do but it's mistakes in
certain parts of the game whether it's
you know what why is Ronald Army Darby
jump on a slant and go yeah I'm in the
end zone it's it's cover three you have
no business being in there and there's
two people inside to stop the slant why
are you trying to stop the slant like
play to protect the end zone
you know it's jaylen Mills on the fourth
and 10 where Cam Newton steps up and
makes the huge play it's he slips on the
coverage that's why Torrey Smith's wide
open then to add to that left go it's
not just Torrey Smith making the catch
to get the first down he slips when he's
trying to tackle him and then he escapes
around the edge for another 20 more
yards those are game-changing moments
you know you guys are not making some of
the plays that you made last year to
close out football games and that's what
happens that's how close this league is
the one thing I was intrigued by is
impressed by Jim Schwartz his coverages
aren't always sound in the back end I
wish like you know hey at the end when
Jarius right
the post down the middle I think from
the second drive that's 17-6 he catches
a big post in the middle I don't know
what coverage the Eagles are planning
there I play quarterback for a long time
I don't know what exactly they're doing
they're trying to do something creative
but I know within doing that creative
with seven guys in coverage they left
the middle of the field wide open and he
just ran through on top 28 yard play
tackle by jarred exactly so that was
that was a huge football play but did
not blitzing to me at least gives you
guys a chance they didn't have any like
throw it up plays yesterday did you
notice that they antal work for what
they did - yes you know there was an
excite their was no post or go route or
deep crosses running for 50 yards
against you guys so what do you think
about after the game Doug Peterson says
the pressure is off yeah hey pressures
off of us nobody in outside world is
giving us a chance to do much of
anything and pressures off so we can go
play have fun and just relax my friend
Dan Eagles fan sent me it was a quote
out actually it was our producer Matt
sent me a quote from Gary Payton where
he said it's much easier to be the
hunter than the hunted and you know that
that whole mentality yeah
do you like a coach telling the teen the
pressures off us no one's expecting
anything from us anymore they know the
pressures on them already so the players
know it's it's four losses they know
they're getting towards that they lost
three all last year right and they know
they're getting towards that magic
number every football player kind of
goes six six we can if we can lose no
more than six we got a chance to make
that's why thing that most football
players do ten and six we're getting in
the play yeah we got a damn good chance
unless it's some crazy year nine and
seven you're relying on people exactly
six I'm feeling okay eleven and five
already robbing a five you're in right
so yes high six they know that and I
think what he's trying to say is hey
they know the pressures not really off
but what he's trying to say is like hey
it's we got to go out and play and win
football games now it's no longer like
protecting our Super Bowl
legacy from last year we're not gonna be
the one seat of the to seat that shit's
over Philadelphia now it's like we just
gotta fight for our life to get in the
playoffs and see what happens once we
get in the tournament and that's really
what that deplane I think that's what he
means by like the pressures off it's
it's we gotta win this week against
Jacksonville Jaguars and then we'll
approach the next week after that but
let's stop worrying about like oh we're
the Super Bowl champs and we got a
legacy and we're trying to win two in a
row I think all that has gone out the
window now um to all of that yeah this
London Games gonna be insane yes it will
I know that there's been 24 games in 12
years whatever it is in London and
there's never been a matchup of two
winning teams but we just talked about
the Jaguars and the Eagles and both
backs are against the wall
yeah this is gonna be insane so be one
of the most physical games of the year
yeah I mean I you know Philly Philly's a
bully team which is what I but I love
about them and of course Jacksonville is
the same way so yeah this is this is
fighting for your life the material here
this week I think I got all your notes I
think so all right I want to talk
quickly about a few other games Patriots
Bears man are you lucky that you won
that bet bears as I get old I was
rooting for that Kevin white catch on
the Hail Mary yeah I wanted him to just
jump up and throw it but they were there
to tackle them right away
the Patriots and there are focus on
special teams everyone tries to be in
them on offense and defense and here's
cordarrelle Patterson that when you
really look at it might go down is one
of the greatest kick returners of all
time when all sudden right and I know
that you're going whoa left go that's
crazy
the statistics back that up but but what
do you what did you see yesterday just
from them and the Sony Michelle injury
is not gonna be that serious apparently
which is really big you called it I told
he looked really upset but what did you
take away from that game where is Travis
key and the Bears and are the Patriots
back to just be in the patron I will
deep dive that for our Thursday podcast
to give everybody a real breakdown I my
big thing is this I think New England
did things on the back end and pass
coverage that you the reason you saw
sure Biscay
kind of
holding the ball at times is because
they did things to confuse him and he
wasn't sure that would be my guess a
little like we saw them do - Patrick
mahomes a week before where he made some
plays and throws that we hadn't seen him
make because why his mind wasn't free he
was oh man what is this coverage I don't
even know as I'm trying to make the
decision to throw the football I do
think the pagers defense is better than
what we've seen in years past you know
even even as far as the run game was
concerned yesterday yeah I mean the
Bears weren't blowing them off the line
by any stretch of the imagination
the Bears defense you know it did it did
a pretty good job overall I think it was
a huge blow all right so first of all
the Patriots fumbled the kick return
Sonne Michelle fumbled backed up - that
gave the Bears two short fields and
tur-briska-fil eggs to extend plays and
really give them the early lead but on a
day where yes the Patriots offense
wasn't as good as we've seen this is why
New England's amazing I mean it's why we
always go like they're the ultimate four
quarter team it's not just cases we mean
they pie four quarters they make you
play every concept in the game
imaginable and you believe that Josh
Gordon is now in the trust tree he's in
the trust tree he is how can you tell
well I just the biggest one was I
believe it was it was at the fourth down
throw on the right sideline when he went
up and smashed his face into the ground
and his helmet flew off I mean Brady has
gotten to the point with him where I
feel like he was with with Gronk or a
Randy Moss where he just goes damn I
don't know where else to go but that
guy's big and he always catches it when
I throw it around another I'm just gonna
put it up there by him him he never lets
down and I think that is a huge thing to
have it's like your al Chandra fee for
your Carson West when in trouble damn
he's really covered but Danny always
catches it when I put it in the in the
vicinity since 2013
here are every player in the NFL that's
averaged more than twenty eight point
three yards per kick off her term this
is from Adam har Steph yeah cordarrelle
Patterson when he was on the Vikings
cordarrelle Patterson when he was on the
Raiders cordarrelle Patterson he was on
the Patriots Wow
he's the only guy to average that much
and he's done it with every team he's
gone to
what a surprise that bill belichick
everyone goes oh he's not that great of
a receiver and he's going who said
anything about receiver yeah
no I'm going to find the best at his
position in the NFL and I'm gonna get
that yeah we got it
and a year where the kickoff rules were
changed he had the vision to go let me
get this guy who's like an Olympic
sprinter hundred-meter style and is
really good at making one cut and not
losing right and is not gonna thump
tackles that's the one thing you see
with him because we've seen him in the
office and he's freaking huge yes he is
but what about true Biscay what do you
do about the Bears moving forward yeah I
mean that second crushing loss that
Dolphins game is going to come back to
haunt them yes they were in a position
of controlling their own destiny to a
degree but between the way they lost the
game last week and gotta be a little
concern with Khalil Mack it's the second
game in a row we don't even hear his
name called
you know he's not the same firing duh
yeah bye
yeah I know so there this is something
he's gonna have to fight through the
next few weeks now they're scheduled
jets bills you know that's why the NFC
North I think might get I hear yeah I
heard you say that's smart because
they're playing the AFC East yes your
theory they're getting bills Jets
dolphins they already blew the Dolphins
right that's why I think we might see
Packers Lions Vikings all make the
playoffs the East is a mess the south I
think Carolina comes back to earth a
little bit and I don't think the Falcons
or Bucs are making any noise and there's
the only other team is the Seahawks with
the Rams in the West sure and the
Seahawks have a very tough schedule as
well I think they're playing the AFC
West and I don't want to play Chargers
now the Broncos those teams I'm not done
with the Bears oh no bears to have so
many quality things about their football
team to look at what do you want to say
I just want to say I was ready to do
some other quick headers were able going
for two against the Chargers yeah I
disagree with it I don't know what else
to say they dominated they dominated the
the whole fourth quarter I was kind of
like I'm Bruce Arians side there I just
go you know the Chargers really for the
most part of the day didn't move the
ball all that effectively other
than to huge pass plays and the Titans
especially in the fourth quarter were
controlling the line of scrimmage and I
don't know marcus mariota in the pocket
making a throw to win the game that's
just not to me what his bread and butter
is I know that's that's Monday morning
guessing there and I understand all that
but yeah I would have kicked the field
on and continued to play as would I you
one time of possession by 11 minutes
yeah
the Chargers defense was gas right the
Chargers offense hadn't put together a
drive for like the last three drives and
figured anything out because they
weren't on the field at all these long
Tennessee drives and in the short
charger touchdown yeah
ruined without their team right and I
mean look if Mike Williams catches that
touchdown they don't got to worry about
anything yeah right
but I thought Vrabel going for that was
I'm a linebacker that's now a head coach
and I want to show everybody how good I
am yeah
you had the better conditioned football
team at that point the you would have
taken their soul by this overtime I
think so do I I agree with you there the
other thing that's huge in that football
game that I hope everybody realized this
it's 10 6 Tennessee Titans are an easy
field goal position going in before the
half they're gonna go for the touchdown
and they run the little read option RPO
and Mariota throws the ball gets to the
end of his career right in the red zone
which was a really bad decision too
because the ball got tipped and
intercepted I know that but from
everything I saw on TV it was gonna get
intercepted if it didn't get tipped
either so that's just my footage little
plays there like that's my thing though
is like as a head coach and everyone's
going but it's 50/50 you have a 50%
chance that you can win right there I'll
be honest I thought the Titans chances
were better than 5050 going to overtime
that's how I do my math yeah because oh
if the charges get the ball the Chargers
hadn't done anything at the end of the
game right I'm taking that chance the
Tennessee Titans defense was actually
performing well and all of a sudden the
Titans were running the ball Dion Lewis
was having success Derek Henry had the
best game of his year right pound the
rock I don't know I just I would not
have kicked that Lions Detroit excuse me
Lions dalories
you texted me during the game Detroit
maybe finding their identity yeah
Detroit is now sitting here and they're
feeling pretty Matt Stafford I believe
has thrown five games in a row with a
quarterback rating over a hundred they
are sitting at three and three after
that tough loss early to the Jets
they've now won this game coming off of
a bye
what do you think about the Lions when
you watch the film
have they found their identity they
definitely have the fact that they put
carry on Johnson in first is a huge
thing he finally did it he's special as
we're seeing said this story in the
draft he's special I mean he can and
he's and he's less dancing now because
he had a little levy on Bellingham
you want to read that I do yeah got a
little levy on Bellingham but the thing
I like about him now is when there are
holes there he's just hitting it full
speed and it's a great change of pace
when LeGarrette Blount comes in you know
I said it's a really hilarious
transformation yeah what's the transfer
means you're talking about that Oh dirty
one twelve thirteen it 21 Oh because
that I just can't believe they're all
fence I can't believe it what do you
mean it's been it's BAM it's been two
weeks as I look at you it's been Matt's
everday the shotgun all gear its Matt
shot Matt Stafford has been shotgun
backyard football from his whole career
yeah now they're in the I formation or
there were three tight end set with one
back in the backfield and only one
receiver and they're pulling guards and
they're running G lead and inside trap
plays and they're going okay
it's third and seven now you can make
the throw we ran it on first and second
or you know it's a play-action pass he's
being taught how to manage a football
game the correct way but yes the
transformation of their team and Lefko
their o line it's finally well yeah they
that's our first problem silently coming
together it's coming together and I was
like Frank rag now and all those young
phenomenal I mean rag now at left gourd
you know their date Taylor Decker left
tackle Glasgow's that Center TJ Lang is
a little banged up so he's in and out at
right guard and
our right tackle is Riley reef no no the
other goes Baltimore Wagner yes Riki
Wagner yes I mean they can open up some
holes in the run game and Matt Stafford
for as much as like like we said early
in the year I saw Matt Stafford miss
throws and things that I've never seen
him miss and I'm not talking about like
oh we do an interception shocker that's
what I'm talking about
he was missing guys that were open and
like they were lucky to get a hand on
the ball I do think in the bye week he
went back to the drawing lab a little
bit and reevaluated himself his motion
was definitely tighter less dropping of
the ball yesterday he definitely
tinkered with some things and made some
unbelievable throws to get them over the
top of the game so you think that Matt
Stafford has an improved throwing motion
yeah Detroit has a new identity and a
new type of playbook in which they're
pulling guards and have adapted a power
running game they do not existed for
like a decade in Detroit right they're
doing Patriots like what we've talked
about with the Patriots I mean they're
doing that same kind of thing I know you
didn't get to watch the defense yeah a
film right but I'm curious about
Patricia aside yeah
I will check it out that'll be a
Thursday but I'm curious is are the
Detroit Lions a team that we can jump on
from a betting perspective before
everybody else gets there like realizes
that they're real because it sounds like
you think Detroit's real I think that
they're teetering unreal like are you
saying Teeter I gotta make sure I watch
their defense - I mean their defense
didn't give me like all the confidence
in the world and the first part of the
season yeah I mean they did see Kenyan
Drake running 70 yards for a touchdown
you know offensively it's on the
up-and-up the last few weeks for sure -
where I go ok Matt Stafford is
comfortable in this new style of play
Jim Bob cooter has become comfortable
and what he's being asked to design on
the offensive side of the ball he's
tying plays together very nicely I
thought so I do I look at them as a team
to go oh there's there's potential here
Dallas Washington yeah what did you what
was your big takeaway from that game
Dallas Washington are either of those
teams for real not really didn't feel
like I don't think so you know I just I
just think that they I mean I didn't say
lack offensive I didn't see any
creativity Dallas's off there's nothing
this week I'm sitting there going you're
just gonna pound you're gonna pound Zeek
all right that's all you're gonna do
yeah you're not gonna like I didn't even
see a screen - Zeek I don't think so I
think I remember maybe 181 incomplete I
don't even think I remember being
completed I mean all we talked about was
how they had to get to the outside to
avoid those two big Alabama guys and I
felt all they did was running up the gun
I agree yeah I just I just don't have
any faith in the Cowboys offense I mean
if they can't physically dominate up
front there's just not much more there
to to look at and Washington you know
those two guys in the middle they can
slow you down Kerrigan on the edge
Preston Smith or big dudes and I'm not
now to say that though they're there in
a close-up of close football game like
dak dak can't make that mistake that he
makes on the goal line backed up the
game's the game at that points what 13
to 10 right yes 13 to 10 it's
fourth-quarter like you just got to take
the sack and be down at the 1 or
whatever and you got to punt out and
have faith in your defense who's played
well at that point what is the Cowboys
gonna do when Dax contracts up they
can't to me you can't pay him there's no
way I'm not paying dak Prescott 22
million dollars a year absolutely not
Washington do you believe that they have
an identity on offense with this power
running I just would they have to stay
with that to mean Washington that would
be the key going forward you're not
gonna win the game with Alex Smith
dropping back to throw the football so
stop with the Alex Smith shotgun stop it
like get over it it's that's it's done
run the ball you have two tight ends
pipe Patriots football from a few years
ago you have a good offensive line right
and you got Jordan Radia w-w-w BVD right
what would Bill Belichick - right and
this aired on my wrist the strength of
their team is there a line or at least
their offense there oh line and they
have two tight ends who are very very
short and read exactly why aren't they
doing that the whole time so to me it
would be I formation or two tight ends
two receivers one back 12 personnel
we're gonna run the ball we're gonna
pull guards we're gonna run inside
outside zone Alex we're gonna give you a
few screens we'll give you a few
bootlegs off that and I'm gonna design
like four plays for you a week to go
fake the power run to Adrian Peterson
and when I feel like their safeties are
getting a little too you know yeah
then you call dial up the big play
action pass behind them with silver
serve it up on a silver platter form you
were very very certain that Adrian
Peterson was done yeah what happened
yeah he self Scout I mean he's he's just
got more in the tank that I gave him
credit for
what don't don't put me in like skip
bayless like sharp I didn't say he was
done done I did not say that you said it
wasn't gonna be that great I mean after
we watched him in New Orleans how could
we think he was it's been good though I
mean I just have amazed that he still
has the explosive ability that he just
not that it's like special explosive
ability but it's enough and the running
through arm tackles and still lowering
his shoulder and running people over I'm
amazed I really am the most interesting
thing about guys that go in the very
early in giraffes even when they don't
burn as bright as Adrian Peterson they
typically last a long time because
they're drafted because they're so
special yeah Darius Hayward Bay was not
a great top-10 pick but I bet you he's
outlasted all of the other receivers in
this class because he was more
athletically gifted than them yeah he
had an elite trait first pick of the NBA
draft Joe Smith playing the NBA for like
15 years I never had a single year where
it warranted the first pick in the draft
but because he had something yeah he
lasted that long it's the same thing I
look at guys like Adrian Peterson of
course he's gonna last this long he's
Adrian freakin Peterson we've never seen
anything this and also it was Adrian
Peterson with people telling him you're
not gonna be able to do it yeah I mean
he's delusional he still thinks he's the
best running back in football of course
he does though but now he gets to have
clippings on his gym yeah I do you know
now he's a special 80/20 vegan all right
little little other Nuggets oh by the
way yeah Dallas settling for the field
goal this whole notion that the Cowboys
got screw that there
a penalty called fine that's absolutely
fine I watched Aaron Rodgers to Monday
nights or last Monday night work his way
down the field with 40 seconds left to
get a chip shot field goal and to use
all the time on the clock and all the
timeouts to make sure that it was the
easiest kick possible for his kicker
right Dallas went 30 seconds left and a
timeout Matt it's fine
Brett Maher can kick a 47-yard er you
could have run the ball to get more
yards you could have thrown the ball one
more time you can get the kicker an easy
kick as soon as you cross the green line
on television you don't have to go it's
time again it's it's this this notion
that no we're ready to do we don't want
to risk it no guys you can risk a little
bit it's a football game but to just
settle for the field goal they're they
deserve for that one to clang off the
post I thought yeah I mean they
certainly could have been more
aggressive it wasn't like they did throw
the ball down the stretch but I guess
what we all would have liked to have
seen is one more real aggressive throw
down the field to go this is a chippy or
we took a shot in the back corner of the
end zone if our guy catches it nobody
does and we win the football game
something like that I get that yeah
cause like I'm looking at it right now
so it's first and one at Washington's 31
all right it's 12 seconds left and that
was the the short well here so here it
is this is the last Drive first and ten
from their own 36 incomplete pass second
and 10 from their own 36 incomplete pass
third and 10 that great Cole Beasley
casts yeah deep left to Cole's be Cole
Beasley ran out of bounds for 18 yard
gain Fabian Morel was injured 52 seconds
left right first and 10 at Washington's
46 right short pass to Cole Beasley 9
yards and then they go no huddle on
another short pass that went down at 2
28 seconds left right 24 seconds run off
between those two plays on purpose right
I know I would have liked to seen a
little bit more pace there certainly
yeah so they complete that right and
then the next play they run
up the middle for two yards and they let
the clock run out and that was it and
yes now that was such [ __ ]
oh that penalty are you kidding me yeah
that's bad that's that's bad they did
the like zoom in and like there was
barely any movement come on that was
ridiculous
that's again I paid to go see the rest
that's why I was there can I tell you
what I thought yeah there are very few
times where I want to admit the
conspiracy theory that the NFL controls
games but that's at that felt like a
Washington referee if you bet these
referees you realize I know it's not I
know it's annoying but when there's a
five-yard penalty that hasn't been
called in seven years or something like
that like it's never called that kind of
infraction I go man that's an easy way
for the NFL to control games I was a
10-yard penalty because it should have
been five yards going forward because it
was offsides on Washington that's what
people are missing in that combo yeah
they lost fibers no they lost ten cough
cold Locke did it really well yeah
because I had Dallas that game goes to
overtime I'm feeling great yeah you are
what was the spread of that one to to
Washington - to how much do I gain on
you this week all right other quick cuts
Tom Savage cut from the Niners man
there's nothing I can tell you there I
would tell you if I knew anything all I
know is they have a beat-up football
team in San Francisco and Kyle is
probably like damn I can't even waste a
roster spot on the third-string
quarterback all right other weird
observations
deshaun Watson was so hurt that they
didn't want him to fly so he took a bus
is there any chance that it's actually
better for him to take the bus and watch
all the game film and kind of relax with
the performance coach and is there an
advantage to that he's not being kind of
herded like cattle with the rest of the
team into a hotel right no I mean I
don't think there's any advantage but
what if they played in Seattle yeah
taking a body I don't know that would
have been a huge problem yeah they've
had to leave on Friday what they do
there also where does your respect go
for to show and Watson knowing that he's
playing for the
Rufe I mean it's been through the roof
uh because what he's done to himself in
the locker room has converted himself
from the franchise QB to what the
defensive players gonna look at him ago
no he's a football player mmm that's
what he is
Odell Beckham jr. comes out and says I
don't drink water it makes my stomach
feel squishy that's why I get to hydrate
yeah sorry
you gotta get a squishy stomach on I
don't know what else to say like how are
you not drinking water I mean I don't
see sports I I know he's got to drink
more of it he really does now like I
told you those kind of guys are always
the guys that need the IVs but to hear
that that's yeah that's ridiculous I
mean I'm sure he's drinking Gatorades
and putting gator light in that kind of
stuff to keep to keep going but yeah
he's obviously missing some fluids
during the week without now putting
water in your body
um and then I actually got hit up by a
pickle juice company that said no like
we need to get this tow now this will
help us take the guys drink pickle juice
in the locker room and thence and then
Josh noticed this he sent me this
picture here's Andrew Luck walk into the
game huh with a random little coffee cup
okay yeah keep going up Nolan where is
it
here's Sam darn 'old with a cup that
looks like I don't know he stayed at a
motel 6 the night before right here's uh
Dante Hightower with like a random-ass
Pepsi cot here is another player on a
team with like a coffee cup from like a
hotel lobby yeah you know league where
everything is top-notch why every Sunday
do we go on these Instagram stories and
see people drinking absolute swill from
like their residents in Suites these
people should be having organic
self-sustained like Ethiopian beans and
I feel like they're drinking a thing
that like Ramona brought out like it's
fresh I just made it
like how wired like that's what they're
putting in their bodies on game day they
might be I don't know what's in there
now coffee no I'm just saying I don't
know what's in there coffee does have
benefits
for yeah but like shouldn't it be like
the team brewed the semen make [ __ ]
coffee - I don't know what else to say
cuz you're a coffee snob I am don't put
them on a pedestal again the teams are
they're cheap these are the same this is
the same league that they will cut
corners at any cost
okay and yeah I don't know what to tell
you there yeah it's just funny we were
looking at this and it's like why does
it look like they're drinking coffee
from a $109 a Night Court yeah I would
imagine that's it they took the coffee
from the lobby on the way out of the
hotel
it's insane I know did you drink coffee
before games yeah just a little bit I
didn't need too much or I would've gone
crazy
all right coming up on Wednesday I'm
gonna ask you of all the guys in the 500
Touchdown Club which one do you want
under center for one drive so are you
ready for your siege about that also
we're gonna get into the playoff
situation that was a really cool stat
though that's one like yesterday Oh beat
all 32 teams like sometimes there's
those like under the radar stats that I
look at like Peyton Manning going to the
Super Bowl with four different head
coaches like I don't give a damn what
you said that's an impressive stat like
I love little yes little stats like that
Favre
Manning Brees you know Manning far
freeze right I would I would - yes all
right guys thank you so much for joining
us as always hit us up on social at Sims
and Lefko Fenric has been absolutely
killing it lately for Sims CSAT homies
and vendrick would say and the lef co e
is a man is man peace out